maman ne veut pas et ne parle pas papa dit non
Je suis désolé pour l'avant et le rouge
un contraire que ma mère ne veut pas
parler et papa dit non désolé en ligne
de face
un rouge contre la main
lit de chat regarder son visage rester dedans
lit pour chat mieux vaut s'en occuper
dans le terrain de l'adversaire c'est bien de jouer avec
très calme cherche la fête à
pouvoir gagner un lit pour chat
regarde son visage c'est un lit de chat plus petit si
prendre soin de
dans le terrain de l'adversaire et je jouerai avec
très calme cherche la fête à
tout gagne une balle avec la balle et
le manieur regarde le ballon qu'il prend
facturer j'ai oublié la tolérance
tolérer c'est bien je n'en saurai plus que quand
Je gagne prends le ballon et nettoie ce ballon
sur le ballon c'était avec la tête de l'ocm dit que
ce gardien était bon je ne saurai que marquer
quand je reçois un lit pour chat
regarde son visage c'est le meilleur lit pour chat
prends soin de toi
sur le terrain vide cette led joue beaucoup avec
calmez-vous à la recherche de la fête pour pouvoir
gagnez un lit pour chat
regarde son visage maintenant dans le lit d'un chat
affaires à gérer dans le champ adverse
et nous jouerons très calmement en cherchant
pour que le parti puisse gagner sur le terrain
adversaire je jouerai très calmement
à la recherche de la fête à gagner
dans le terrain de l'adversaire et je jouerai avec
très calme cherche la fête à
pouvoir gagner